[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the hot seat where we got way over
here
nervous
you know so we all play hot season
before computers clothes and everything
you just want to you know just kick back
put a little bit of spotlight on you get
to know you a little bit better all the
spotlight but don't worry we can warm up
into a we always like to start cold with
a little bit of a sterile bark question
something really catches you off guard
and then we get really dark we'll heat
it up gotcha maybe it gets a little
spicy here but we'll see what happens go
ahead bar hit her off
um
do you like plastic bags or paper bags
oh man that's your most sterile question
yet dude wow plastic why do you like
plastic because it doesn't rip as easy
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
dude what are you dumb or something i do
not know that god
damn you can't get paper bags wet i
never realized this like sibling energy
y'all got until today because like
before like i didn't really sense this
until like today bart was like on a
roasting fire on
twitter like all day long i feel
comfortable with it
yeah feel comfortable with that all
right and i feel like i got two
vietnamese sisters over there
[Laughter]
oh fire bro
there you go
pet peeve
pet peeve
when people are
loud for no reason
you mean like just a big voice
[ __ ]
no you guys are cool whatever but it's
just like
on the plane or like on somewhere where
you're not supposed to be loud and
you're just like obnoxiously loud and
you don't care who's the loudest person
in your circle
so you don't like chinese people
[Laughter]
[ __ ] loud for no reason how would you
say like for no reason like why but like
a loudest friend he's a loudest friend
still a friend so it's all nice and [ __ ]
yeah i'm gonna say um this girl nikki
shout out nikki what's up nicky you loud
ass
[ __ ] nikki like when we're in a group
like she's the one
nicki actually just screaming and [ __ ]
loud loud for no reason they should talk
with claps yes oh one of those ladies
yes
she might have a
ear boogers backed up because i
how are you
once i took out my ear boogers i was
like ooh i talked i talked loud
that's like david so of this room yeah
he's pretty loud he always
i also really hate like just loud noises
like unnecessary noises for no reason
just like describe an unnecessary noise
um
honking or drinking
or like car
isn't that alarms
though they just heard all those kind of
sounds
okay okay get off the vietnamese sisters
back all right i want to sock you for
her bro what please
ask your innocent questions all right
you you came to america in 2006
did you come with your family or did you
come traveling alone i came with my
family so my sister my dad my mom and my
auntie everybody decided to come over
here no we got sponsored over here
because i my mom's sister sponsored us
they they came kind of late right yeah
like did they say i'm going to america i
want a better life no it was more of a
situation where paperwork just went
through because the whole process is
really really long my mom's been waiting
for like 10 12 years and then i just she
just happens to have a family in vietnam
yeah waiting for the papers to go
through yeah that happens yeah and so
like once the paper went through she
just happens to have a family so her
whole family can
go with her when you're a kid
and you came to the states and then you
don't you didn't know english right all
of a sudden you're just thrown into the
school all this [ __ ] how was that like
it was um i think it was
a situation where it was like ignorance
is bliss because i was like i didn't
understand what they were saying i just
had no comprehension in it loki just
kind of went so fast to where i'm just
like or maybe i'm just like suppressing
those thoughts and feelings that i felt
back then were you around asians um no i
moved to oxnard so it was a lot of
hispanics
yeah and what was your first impression
of america
mexico cold i came in
during december i came on december 25th
so christmas christmas
merry christmas america yeah
my taiwanese relatives when they come
here in the summer they're still wearing
jackets and [ __ ] yeah i'm like it's cold
here like cold cold so i have a bunch of
vietnamese friends that came in their
childhood too right but they never shook
off their accent
but you
how did you do that i'm not sure i think
it's a lot of television i watched a lot
of spongebob and
the food network and anthony bourdain
yeah
is that how you got to cooking yeah
is that how you got into cooking um yeah
anthony bourdain definitely inspired me
to be
kind of fascinated with food because he
um came at an angle where it was just
beyond the food so that
yeah that intrigued me
so you
um growing up you knew you wanted to do
something with food no i i didn't when
was your first moment where you're like
i'm going to cooking school when my mom
wanted me to be a nurse and i knew that
i didn't
what what made you go i'm gonna nurse
what what made you say i'm gonna [ __ ]
nurse because that's not what i wanted
to do i never felt a passion for it i
i'm really really scared of blood
um yeah i just didn't want to do that
what about blood and cooking does that
freak you out
like a steak no what part of blood are
you afraid of that like people getting
cut and like just
drawing blood and [ __ ]
it makes my legs weak okay yeah like
even in the kitchen when somebody like
cuts themselves or when i cut myself i'm
just like uh like wow you gonna jump in
the freezer cool down yeah let's see
damn so it became like
like one of those things where the asian
parent goes you must do this and you're
like oh it wasn't even a situation like
that it was kind of like they kind of
expected me to be and i was like okay i
think i'll do that and so throughout
high school i was like volunteering at
the hospital just like setting myself up
for this path and then at the end when i
was really about to go to school like in
like during senior year doing the
paperwork and stuff like that i was like
i really don't think i can finish this i
really don't think that i can go through
with this so then yeah so then i was
just like what do you really like to do
and i'm like i love to eat i don't know
how to cook [ __ ] it just go to culinary
school and then when when your mom heard
that was she like you're not part of
this family no more um we had a
disagreement but at the end of the day i
like stood my ground and that like she
realized that she couldn't change my
mind
what was the biggest dish you told your
mom biggest whole life what was the
what's the biggest or the funniest thing
you ever called her
i don't remember like a fat cow or
something no
did you get into a fist fight with her
i almost
almost when i was like oh big enough to
like fight back and then she realized oh
[ __ ] yeah like you're big enough your
mom must be small
oh [ __ ] yeah she's like 4 11. did you
guys come here on the same seat then
both you guys said in one chat bye
that's the right answer that's the right
answer
what what do you think of your mom's
cooking
i mean it's what makes my cooking really
special because i learned she's not the
type of
person that would teach you how to cook
because she's like you just add this at
this you feel it you just know you smell
it so i can't learn like that but i've
learned through
tasting her food
of like what i want my food to taste
like if it wasn't cooking what would you
be doing
if it wasn't cooking she's like nurse
no
i think i would be like in like
maybe like just print modeling something
like that yeah like i love like just the
fashion world as well why did what also
you would have got done something with
clothes yeah
if you're in charge of
uh the ai the future ai group
describe what you think the ideal man
should be and what would you create dude
ideal me to come out and create this
ideal man yeah ooh ideal man
i think black
okay we got that one
what else quick i'm dead no
big and tall
fashion sense
oh wow
i think i date this guy already wow
likes to eat yeah wow loves vietnamese
food yeah maybe i know her more than she
knows herself yeah you you treat me what
is it what is it what would it be
huge heart
um oh man i think it's it i for me it
always goes beyond the physical because
if i can't like have a conversation with
you if i can't like connect with you on
like
be on the surface level then i can't be
with you so anything that's like if
you're mentally challenging me like i
love that [ __ ]
hmm
who's your high school crush then coming
to america
and then zac efron for real yeah and
like damn he's so fine yeah [ __ ] i don't
see you in vietnam man
zac efron all the way do you still feel
that way now
he's cute but not yeah he's not the same
not the high school musical not not that
cool now we all in this together yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
he aged today's video is brought to you
by upstart it's almost a new year so
it's time to start thinking about your
resolutions how about adding financial
freedom to the list with a little bit of
help from upstar upstart is the fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether you're
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment upstart knows you're more than
just your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart uses your credit and
current employment to find you a smarter
rate for your loan with a five minute
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans from 1 000 up to 50 000
dollars wow
and receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
so find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today by going to
upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com
off the record and don't forget to use
this specific url so they know that we
sent you go get it baby loan amounts
will be determined by your credit income
and other information that you provide
on the loan application go to
upstart.com off the record and get your
financial freedom today who's your goat
like besides anthony bourdain as far as
like uh tv chefs growing up like who was
your favorite to watch favorite i would
say giada de laurentiis
yeah
i thought she was just always really
beautiful to watch like pleasant to
watch
um and she was always on at three and
that was after school so i've just
always watched her
you've been watching giada since you
were a kid yeah oh that's like really
your thing huh yes
like i didn't realize it then but like
that's what i would always watch like
just the food network i love chopped um
all of that [ __ ] i love the cookies if
you if you couldn't cook vietnamese food
french food french fruit that's damn
near vietnamese food
is the cooking technique similar like
because of the french style cuisine so
in like mixed with vietnamese food um
similar yes there are like certain
differences because like vietnamese
people we don't really care about like
techniques that much like different
knife cuts and all of that stuff it's
more of just like flavor profile they're
pretty their clothes and flavor profile
but not really like techniques okay i
got a question for you
if you're in charge of
real laughing
you throw me off
if you had to rename
the
five most popular vietnamese foods
with std names which ones would they be
which one would be aids which one would
be gonorrhea two big pass hard pass hey
that's our first pass of the house we're
at the 12 minute and 14 second moment of
the show i like the premise well we like
to start getting a little bit deeper a
little bit spicier with our questions
get to know you a little bit better okay
okay all right when was the last time
you cried
yesterday night damn oh [ __ ] you're too
sensitive please please do tell yeah um
it was during dinner service and it was
just like stress and all of that just
combined and me having to prep for like
two days ahead and having just people in
my ear and it was just like building and
building so i just had to step away
let the tears run down for a bit and
then gather myself and went back to the
kitchen um oh because you were serving
yes it was i got it because she had
onions no it was drink service yeah does
that happen a lot like it does it gets
stressful yeah it gets real and i it was
like my name on the line too so it was
like people referring to me as like chef
so i was basically head chef so it was a
lot
do you feel like you semi thrive in the
stress though that's something that
makes you yeah did you did you cry
during the the pop-up that you did
recently too or no no because i know
that was pretty stressful too yeah no
what was your biggest obstacle along
this journey like can you look back and
be like that that [ __ ] [ __ ]
traumatized me like a [ __ ] what
journey like career-wise or
yeah like just coming to america i would
just say like um anything that comes to
mind that was like yo that should [ __ ]
me up dude yeah your movie you're the
main character i think it was a
situation where um
rick and i put out a video where we
um talked about our open relationship
and it just i wasn't ready for the
amount of people that were gonna like
that had a lot to say that had their
opinion like a lot of guys started
hitting on you no no like it was more
like just [ __ ] talking oh like they
didn't like and oh they didn't accept
that yeah like oh it's crazy it's like
this is your [ __ ] yeah yeah no we put
that video we made that video with the
intention of like this is our this is
our story this is our perspective like i
feel like we could bring a different
perspective to the table yeah and it
just didn't turn out like that and it
almost
how did people receive it like were they
like you're [ __ ] wrong or like yeah
they were basically like oh she's not
into him or he's a semp um what uh she's
a [ __ ]
like she just doesn't like him like that
stuff like that you know and it like
just
a lot of like outside voices and i
wasn't ready for that at the time yeah
[ __ ] everybody
they all project me you know for sure
yeah like that was definitely like
really really difficult because of like
the amount of like opinions that were
pushed upon me that i wasn't ready for
so the follow-up to that is i think when
you're in the public eye like we all
experience something along the lines of
that right but then like
i've seen a lot of people stop social
media after getting canceled after doing
things but then you decided to keep
going
um what got you to go like you know what
[ __ ] these opinions
um
i think it was more of a situation where
i was like i don't have to put my
relationship out there like that like i
at the end of the day we know who we are
we know what we are and so we're just
like [ __ ] them whatever so now i'm just
i just focus on what i do and that's
cooking so i use the platform to just
push my career more than just like oh
this is my life look at my house look at
my boyfriend's i closed it up a little
more made it more focused on on the
career on the food yeah yeah
[Music]
if you had a piece of advice uh for
other aspiring
either chefs or
little immigrant vietnamese ladies or
whatever it might be what would you give
off based off of everything you've
experienced um pay attention to what
what fills your cup like pay attention
to what really makes you feel fulfilled
and whole even if it feels scary even if
it feels like it's never gonna work out
like once you align yourself in that
situation once you align yourself to
receive the things that you want
it's gonna come to you
wow very wise if you had to deal with
either a itchy butt or itchy vagina for
the rest of your life what would you
deal with that's a good question that
it's important that we all learn from
that yeah yeah i'd like to answer that
afterwards
and there's nothing i can do about it no
it's one or the other it's one or the
other and it's so itchy where you have
to scratch it in public yeah oh in
public
or you try to hide i mean try to go
behind the bush or something but it's
it's it's pretty crazy it's your
butthole i'm gonna say butthole really
really yeah i don't know having an itchy
vagina i don't know yeah i think
butthole's better too because you don't
want people to think you're masturbating
in public yeah you get like a sex crime
on you and [ __ ] and like it's your
butthole you can kind of like scratch it
like when you're sitting you know and
you can put your arm behind you they
don't know what you're doing like if
it's vagina you kind of have to like put
your legs in between something and it's
just weird yeah that's how i scratch my
vagina
you know so what's one of the hardest
things you've done for your career one
of the hardest um
i think it has to be like cooking for
people in real life
because that is your career yeah yeah
i've done it before but it was under the
guides of like the the chefs that have
like experience like years and years of
experience that's guiding us through the
kitchen and we just have to like prep
for him whatever so like running your
whole operation i see that's the hardest
part you got all the liability and
building like a team that could work
well together
um handling like little [ __ ] yeah
dang
what's your advice on team building oh
advice on team building
um
like only asians or
keep one race
on team building i think team building
really comes from like
you
because if you are
i i think a lot of times people think of
like your team like if it's my team then
i'm the leader it's i i have this
mentality of like if it's my team i am
serving them like i
if you're working for me i'm gonna make
sure that i take care of you because i
know that if i take care of you you're
gonna do
better work than
having you feel like you're working for
me
so i just like make sure to treat my
team members no matter who they are
really well because at the end of the
day like they know how much they're
getting paid and they know that i'll
take care of them no matter what
yeah very good snaps for that yeah where
do you feel like you've learned that
from like do you feel like that's
something that was always a part of you
or do you feel like this is something
that was very intentional when you're
trying to work with the team i think
it's from my experience of working with
leaders that have big egos um that was
that was it you're like that's not gonna
be me yeah that's not gonna be me which
one of your family members is the most
fun when they're drunk workers my dad
your dad my dad what what's so fun about
drinking with them um i mean i've drank
i've literally like have partied with
him ever since i was over in vietnam
they don't have an age
limit whatever yeah so like i would be
the person that
drinks drinks with him and then that is
the wildest thing that i do remember is
like when there were night life
like restaurants there's
like here it's like oh over 21. out
there you see family bro like it's like
two o'clock in the morning and there's a
[ __ ] baby and mom's drinking and the
whole family's partying together i would
go to the i would tell people this all
the time and they don't believe me i'm
like i would go to the club with my
parents and just chill like just hang
out and party with them that's time
there's that street in um saigon where
it's like hella [ __ ] party i forgot
the name of it sesame
sesame sesame street
my first experience crazy [ __ ] is like
you know there's like karaoke bars
there's like bars and then there's like
um you know little chairs out on the
patio there's
shisha smoking or whatever and if you
look closely there's people on dates
whatever but then there's full families
yeah drinking
having a blast and there'll be like a
table full of kids just hanging out and
eating and just sitting around
and everyone's just getting wasted
obviously the kids aren't drinking well
at least not that i know they're like
picking up cockroaches and [ __ ]
but it's it's like a family environment
and i was like this is the craziest
thing i've ever seen but it's that's
just like the norm yeah just families
that hang out i remember my family
owning a restaurant in vietnam and um
there were like private rooms and there
was a private like dinner going on in
one of those rooms and it was my dad's
friends and i would i was drinking with
them and then i just remember like just
being getting drunk and going back to
the room like my room and i can just
hear like my mom like where's where's
dway where's toy and then they come in
and they find me and we had to go
somewhere and we had to get dressed but
i literally got out of the bed and like
just laid back on the floor because i
was so wasted and that was me that was
me in vietnam so i was little little
yeah now you're huge that's huge massive
how dare you
you